also man muss sich mal vorstellen jeder
bürger hätte sein eigenes punktekonto
und pluspunkte kann man beispielsweise
sammeln indem man nett zu seinen
nachbarn ist und häufig seine eltern
besucht - punkte da geben beispielsweise
gibt es wenn man sich nicht an
verkehrsregeln hält das gibt's ja schon
gar nicht bei uns wäre dann nicht in die
kategorie a guter mensch gehört kommt
auf die schwarze liste und könnte unter
anderem schwierigkeiten bei der
wohnungssuche bekommen hört sich an wie
ein schlechter scherz ist in china aber
realität big data und big brother führen
dort zu massenüberwachung schlechthin
wie das genau funktioniert ob die
regierung ihre bürger damit tatsächlich
erziehen kann und was die chinesen davon
halten jetzt bei pixum science fiction
hier gibt's jeden tag faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen und dankte für den spannenden
vorschlag bei whatsapp dann bekommt ihr
täglich die videos früher als auf
youtube der link dazu ist in der video
beschreibung derzeit laufen erst einmal
mehr als 40 pilotprojekte in china aber
bis 2020 soll das weltweit beispiellose
sozial kreditsystem flächendeckend
eingeführt werden konkret handelt es
sich dabei tatsächlich um ein digitales
punktekonto hier werden die guten von
den schlechten bürgern unterschieden und
das digitale führungs konto hat
weitreichende konsequenzen für jeden
einzelnen
haltet euch fest denn jetzt zitiere ich
mal das ziel des ganzen vorhabens das im
regierungsplan festgehalten ist
die vertrauenswürdigen sollen frei unter
dem himmel umherziehen können während es
den in verruf geratenen schwer gemacht
wird einen einzigen schritt zu tun
oje noch mehr in die privatsphäre eines
menschen eindringen geht schon fast gar
nicht mehr ab 1000 gesammelten
pluspunkten gehört man zu den guten
bürgern die sich nichts zuschulden
kommen haben lassen aber wie bekommt man
als chinese oder chinesen pluspunkte
beispielsweise in die man anstandslos
seine rechnung zahlt politisch nicht
auffällt und sich auch immer im
straßenverkehr an die regeln hält auch
das verhalten im netz und in social
media netzwerken wird beobachtet und
bewertet
in einigen regionen wird sogar überwacht
ob man regelmäßig seine eltern besuchte
und ob man ihnen finanziell unter die
arme greift oder aber zumindest im
haushalt hilft erfasst werden sollen
alle über
zehn jahre die dann alle auch mit stufe
also 1000 punkten starten die behörden
erfassen ob man sich beispielsweise in
der freiwilligenarbeit engagiert ob man
spendet oder ob man festgenommen wird
wenn man beispielsweise 1000 jahren für
einen guten zweck spendet gibt es fünf
punkte oben drauf wenn man eine
auszeichnung von der stadt bekommt ganz
sind 30 pluspunkte und das kann sich
rentieren wenn wir den ölstand von 1.300
punkten auf seinem konto verbucht
bekommt rabatte beispielsweise auf die
wasserrechnungen die zahlen sind dann
hat man natürlich auch die besten
chancen befördert zu werden bzw
überhaupt einen job zu bekommen und na
klar wollen auch manche schwiegerväter
das punktekonto des potenziellen
partners ihrer tochter kennen wer
dagegen auf stufe c mit nur noch 600
punkten absagt oder gar darunter ist
bekommt nur schwer eine wohnung oder
einen kredit schon jetzt stehen
millionen von chinesen auf der schwarzen
liste weil sie vom system für ihre
sünden bestraft werden und so zur strafe
beispielsweise keine flüge oder züge
mehr buchen können quasi hausarrest oder
eine abgeschwächte form des gefängnisses
ein kleines bisschen erinnert das an die
schufa in deutschland doch die gibt ja
nur auskunft über die finanzielle
situation eines menschen und nicht seine
moralische private und polizeiliche
vorgeschichte und nicht nur als
privatperson wird man in china bewertet
sondern auch als unternehmen um
zuschläge für öffentliche aufträge zu
bekommen muss man erst einmal das
punktekonto der firma vorlegen die
meisten chinesen und chinesen nehmen es
einfach hin oder sie müssen es in dem
überwachungsstaat hinnehmen und viele
sehen aber auch die vorteile das system
ermutige einen nur noch mehr dazu gute
dinge zu tun und schließlich werde so
auch die sicherheit in den städten
gewährleistet zudem könne man so gut
erkennen ob der gegenüber ein guter oder
schlechter sein
dazu muss man aber auch sagen dass die
chinesen quasi mit solchen ideen groß
geworden sind im kommunismus gab es für
jeden eine akte in der die politische
haltung regelverstöße und private infos
aufgeführt waren zudem ist die
öffentliche überwachung in china schon
seit längerer zeit viel krasser
ausgeprägt als wir es hier in
deutschland kennen etwa 180 millionen
überwachungskamera sind im ganzen land
verteilt 2020 sollen es an die 600
millionen sein
die geht darin sind natürlich
gesichtserkennungsprogramm und so konnte
erst vor kurzem ein von den behörden
gesuchter mann zwischen 60000 anderen
zuschauern und zuschauerinnen in einem
riesigen stadion festgenommen werden
büros und studentenwohnheime betritt man
mittlerweile nur noch via
gesichtserkennung und den einzelnen
restaurants kann man mittlerweile
mittels gesichtserkennung bezahlen auf
öffentlichen toiletten gibt es pro
gesicht 60 zentimeter klopapier mehr
aber nicht für den kameras kommt der
gewaltige datenpool des internets das
mehr als 770 millionen chinesen nutzen
zudem wird viel bargeldlos bezahlt und
so kommt big data und big brother
zusammen alibaba amazon und so weiter
verfolgen das online verhalten der user
und sagen es voraus kurios denn
eigentlich hatten sich diktaturen
weltweit immer vor dem internet
gefürchtet denn klar darüber können sich
die bürger informieren und sich
zusammentun doch china nutzt data jetzt
eben für die eigenen zwecke und will
diesen digitalen möglichkeiten seine
bürger erziehen gleichzeitig geht die
regierung so auf nummer sicher dass das
einparteiensystem erhalten bleibt
kritiker und kritikerinnen vergleichen
das ganze mit orwell und warnen
eindringlich davor dass auch andere
staaten nachziehen könnten und
sicherlich ist es auch nur noch eine
frage der zeit bis die belohnung bzw
bestrafungen ausgebaut werden wir halten
euch dazu auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
abonniert geht es um auch auf englisch
denn auch da also hier gibt es immer
wieder videopremieren sie hier
draufklicken und hier geht es weiter mit
tender von james camerons revolution
harry data storage bis bald hoffentlich
auch auf dem englischen kanal csu
stay tuned